yeah i mean so we set up lambda school
to be a counter to all of that
right so what if they're a world where
you only paid if you're successful
and then it eliminates all of the
incentive to do all of the shady stuff
that the rest of for-profit education is
doing
now there's still things that it doesn't
eliminate which you correctly pointed
out like you still have to put time and
effort in there's nothing we can do
to absolve that oh you can't
go back in time and let people change
their decision and give them back nine
months of learning
this was the stupidest response from
this idiotic journalist
person with an axe to grind who i will
have on the program and i will take him
to task i didn't want to do it with you
here i'll get your side i'll get him on
here next if he's
brave enough to come on here and explain
what his axe to grind is but shame on
you new york magazine for letting this
person
do this ridiculous article in the face
of you trying to solve education
and the reason everybody knows about isa
is that i want to make a cry here austin
i see you getting a little emotional
don't get emotional but i just want to
say
i did not understand what the isa was i
was not attuned to what you're doing in
the mission
and the world especially in silicon
valley and out of it now
now understand what an isa is and the
value of it and i understand
universities are now watching lambda
and because you're the tip of the spirit
they're following you and now they're
going to do isas this is correct right
correct